hey Brian I'm Katy snoots I'm a youtuber
who focuses on beauty tutorials today
I'm going to be showing you my top tips
on how to cover dark circles if you want
to know how keep on watching so I get
asked an awful lot about how best to
cover dark circles and under-eye bags
and I've learned a lot of tips and
tricks recently so I wanted to share
them with you
first up cold spoon put it in your
fridge and keep it there and then every
morning before you apply a makeup you
can simply press and hold the cold spoon
on your bags now this is definitely
gonna like decrease puffiness you're
gonna have to still work a little bit on
covering the dark circles but this will
definitely take some of that puffiness
down my second top tip is to try and
increase the blood circulation around
this area for that I'm gonna be using a
facial roller you can get these on the
high street for really affordable price
and you just simply roll this up and
down your skin this is just going to
increase blood flow pick your skin up
and make it look a lot brighter and it's
fun as well I would also say it's a
great idea to start using an eye serum
or an eye cream just around this area
Pat it in before you go to sleep every
single night I've got one here from
utopia skincare it's an instant firming
eye serum which i think would be a great
bonus in your skincare regime for this
tutorial though I'm gonna be using
something slightly different this is an
eye cream
it's the intense glow for eyes and dark
circle corrector this is just like an
eye cream but has a bit of a tint as
well so it's really going to help to
brighten the under eye area as well I'm
gonna take this on my ring finger you
always want to use your ring finger when
applying creams around the eyes because
it's the kind of most gentle finger so
you're not gonna drag your skin you're
not going to cause more wrinkles
as you can see it kind of brightens and
adds a bit of a glow as well distracts
from the dark circles if you're really
suffering with kind of discoloration
under your eyes you might find that
there's a lot kind of like purple tones
the best way to cover this is to
counterbalance it with an orange toned
color corrector or concealer
this one's from Clinique and it's the
beyond perfecting super concealer these
ones can be quite pigmented so I'm just
going to go quite heavy and do not panic
if you look like this we're gonna apply
some foundation on top and just keep
blending that in until it kind of
dissolves with your natural skin colour
now it's time to cover this with some
foundation I've chosen the Too Faced
Born This Way Foundation today love this
is medium to full coverage so it's
definitely going to cover this orange
Ness give it a shake and pump some out
onto the back of your hand and then you
can apply it with a buffing brush so I'm
just patting that in and as you can see
is covered all of that orange Ness but
also completely hidden my under-eye bags
I'm also going to take a smaller like
concealer brush and just buff that in as
close to my lash line as possible to
make sure that we've got rid of all that
orange finally I'm gonna place some
concealer under my eyes I just like to
add a tiny bit more concealer I'm using
my NARS creamy concealer this is a shade
lighter than my skin because this also
helped me to kind of contour my face as
well and again with the eye cream so I'm
just patting this in gently under my
eyes
now I'm not going to set this look with
a powder because powder underneath your
eyes can end up being quite cakey and
you don't want to draw any more
attention to this kind of area of your
face so this should last all day because
we've built a couple of layers of this
off for now
I really hope you've enjoyed this video
and learnt lots of tips and tricks if
you enjoyed it be sure to comment below
share with your friends and be sure to
subscribe to glamour UK's YouTube
channel
[Music]